Men are in trouble. Mansplaining men spreading me too.
Time's up Takashi 69, regular six,
nine meeting up behind the Shoney's to be buddies, Jaden Smith.
Thankfully, I'm here to help now. Why am I qualified?
Cause I've got a popular podcast, a gender neutral haircut and dude,
I bought whippets off the internet. This is man up
[inaudible] these days,
a lot of young men don't have anywhere to turn with their struggles. I mean,
who they gonna turn to? Dude, Mr. T died. And over the last few years,
thousands of men or women with really low voices have been calling into my
podcast and ask them for suggestions.
But sometimes a phone call does doesn't get it done. You know,
like what pizza delivery, you can talk about it.
But until somebody shows up with the pie, you know what I'm saying?
It's all a bunch of hearsay. But what I am trying to do is, um,
is just show people that somebody cares because I hate feeling like somebody
doesn't care when I need help. And um, and it's the least I can do.
And this week I got a call from a sugary Vixen named Jane and she's a
single mother and she got to a boy named Ricky.
And he's veering heavily into adult that I'm talking to the deep end, you know,
and talking about this boy is getting a little bit long in the nut.
And she said, he's having a lot of problems. If he doesn't want to work,
he doesn't want to motivate. He doesn't want to contribute around the house.
She said some of the best things he's ever done are still alive.
And then he S he lied to people and said that he survived. A Saint Cole
thing is definitely time to see how I can help this young mother with the issues
that she's having with her son. Hey, what's up? How are you? Nice to see you.
Nice to meet you.
Oh, thank you. Why don't you come this way and I'll show you where Rick is.
He's out back as you can see,
he's got his vape out there and he's, that's an adult,
huh? That's an adult.
Man. When you first see Rick,
he definitely looks at the kind of guy that'll reach for your crotch and have a,
you know, a fresh thing, a popcorn in the other hand.
So what's been going on with Rick.
Rick is 29 years old.
He will sit in his room and play video games for eight
hours in a row that hurts my heart.
I will ask him to finish the dishes and days and days will go by
when the dishes don't get finished.
And then I ended up being the one that finishes them.
He doesn't pay rent and losing his father at a young age, I think has had a,
an impact on him to what age was he? When his father passed away, he was 10.
I'm so sorry to hear about his dad. That makes me so sad.
He hasn't had that male role model type thing that shows him how to be a
man. I'm getting ready to kick him out. I mean, look,
let's honest. If Rick.
Doesn't get his act together, as mom's giving him the a kielbasa,
you feel me that sign on our sausage daddy, you know,
it's time for him to just get out of the deep end of.
At least into the shallow into life.
So yeah, dude, what the going on here, man? We know to be honest,
it doesn't seem like you're doing your share here. Well,
who am I hurting? I think you're hurting your mother problem.
It's tough to live together. We live different lifestyles, you know,
I'm younger. So I'm up late, you know,
I'm playing loud music and she wants to go to bed and clean up the house and
I'm sleeping in late and stuff.
You know, a lot of stuff she say you're doing around the house, nothing
smoking weed. She said, you say you smoke a lot of weed. So that's nothing.
What else? And that's nothing. I mean,
do you even have any hobbies that you're working on? Like a lot now or anything?
I have like a Lego set. Okay. So that's nothing also,
you know, Legos is for children and we know it is, it says on the box six to 14.
So when those kids see you show up, they're like, what the happened to this kid?
I know your father passed away. And.
You know, my father passed away when I was young.
And I didn't know for years that I needed him to be around to tell me what to
do. You know.
Sometimes when that happens,
you don't want to grow up because of the person who you want to see,
you grow up the most isn't lot.
Not anymore. Like you still have a really good opportunity in your life to,
to care about your mother and, and be a good son. Yeah.
And I feel like if we have opportunity for you to help your mother out, man,
you can, you're gonna go from being this child to being really a son.
I feel like I can relate to Rick. You know,
I lost my father at a young age and from him losing his father,
it's just left a lot of messiness in his life.
And his mother has been taking care of him. You know, she's still nurturing,
breastfeeding, but without the breast, you know, sands, cone teat.
So it's time for him to learn some skills to help her and to help himself.
Hi gentlemen, welcome to Butler training.
My name is Steve.
My job is to train you and to teach you how to be able to work and earn
a living as being a Butler.
Here's the thing about Butler school. Every Butler I know has their together.
When you see a Butler, you're like, Holy, dude, that's a Butler right now.
Rick looks like a Renaissance. Fair escapee. You know,
one of the hottest outfielders on an Amish women's softball squad.
So if we can get Rick to start doing some things,
to help others like a Butler would,
then he just might start doing some things to help himself.
Part of being a Butler is you have to have nice fingernails.
Do you chew your fingernails, sir? No. No.
Let it look like the pinch of you to get a manicure. You have a nice haircut,
sir. Have a nice mustache look good.
[inaudible].
Juan is actually a buddy of mine, low key.
We met in the elevator about maybe 11 months ago and he teaches me Spanish and I
teach him English and Spanish.
This gentleman is handsome. This gentleman is handsome. And this gentleman,
I would say he needs some work.
Now I actually met Butler Steve through, well. I'll be honest with you,
dude. He's a swinger.
Gentlemen does the outside and the inside so that it looks perfectly clean when
it goes on the table for dinner.
Okay brother. Thanks.
Gentlemen. I want to see a nice professional Butler fold Rick.
He did a great job. That looks like a shirt I would wear.
Oh yay.
Oh,
you need to help him remove the jacket because you don't want him grabbing your
fine jacket and ripping it off your back. You look very professional.
When was the last time you back in?
Uh, I think this is the first time I've ever vacuumed.
In this exercise.
We're going to see what it's like to work with a boss that is irritated. Okay.
Theo. You're the angry homeowner.
You're going to have to stand there like a man and just take it.
I'm about to light this chubby honky up.
Like he stole a sign in the Philippines in the late nineties.
It's time to take it up a notch and get this hairy. Chunka wag.
You ready for the real world?
Look here, boy. The fish was up. What did you cook it in?
It wasn't even cooked. Ah, it wasn't even cooked. Boy.
I'm so very sorry, sir. The next fish that I cook,
you will be absolutely perfectly. I want to cat fish.
I'm very sorry about the fish. We'll learn something. Get a book and learn some.
I'll cause I'm tired of eating bad fish around here. Hey.
The homeowner would not talk to you like that because it would probably be a
lawsuit against it that way.
Don't look at him. Boy, look here you little trucker. Okay.
You won't be able to use that kind of language.
You have to speak to him and be more direct about specifically what's wrong with
what he did.
Okay. You're going to get the Scarlet letter,
boy and you're ready for always fish up.
You know, hoard. It is for me to swallow limp,
Kimberly and some of my friends in their or Remley, little.
You want some violent TIAA. The next creme brulee I make you, sir,
it will be the crispiest crunchiest kimberlé that has ever been
seen decider crisp that up sign.
Or I'm going to put your bones in your. Well,
the problem was I ran out of butane. I still away go away.
Suck it in your job is to take it. You're improving. You look great.
You look very professional.
I hope that this is going to help you maybe later on when you have guests come
to your house.
And buttering is pretty hard work, you know, I thought it would just be,
you know,
you kind of dress up like you're at a funeral and you just kind of steal
silverware on the DL. But Rick is a, is making progress. And I feel like he's,
he's getting the hang of it.
Okay gentlemen. Well, he was good to start with.
These two were very good at the beginning,
but this gentleman improved the most amen brother.
Did you think you improved it a lot today? I think I did. I came.
In here not knowing anything about Butlin Butler in Butler. Okay.
I think it's time new a hood. This training in new action.
Let's have him Butler for someone who I barely even know.
Who's rich and judgmental and John Love it.
Money,
money, money.
Hey. Oh, Theo. Good to see you. Just the Butler. That's him.
Yes, sir. What's your name? My name's Rick. Rick. Nice to meet you. How are you?
This isn't where I actually live. This is my it's an acting studio.
Anyway, come on in.
All right, well let's just start. Can you help me up these stairs? Okay.
Just kind of push. I ain't got to do it,
but I'm lazy. That's all you. Thank you. All right. This way.
I think.
Give Rick and handle Butler ring for a unique male. Like John Love it.
Then he'll be able to handle anything. His mother can throw at him back home.
You can start with a glass of ice please.
I don't hear any dishes being yeah, just staying busy.
Don't complain. I can hear you. It's a very small house. Wow.
This exceeds all expectations. Thank you very much and find my dog.
Okay. I think I found Jerry, sir. Hello? Oh.
Oh. Would you like me to remove Jerry sir? No, no, I liked it.
[inaudible] that's terrific.
You. Oh,
thank you. Uh, you can send it here. Um, you know, Theo,
I've been a little hard on you and you've been sweating so much.
I don't want to watch TV,
but you're a up and I hear everyone say how funny you are.
Could you just send me your acting?
It was a rainy night and there was a couple of bad boys looking to
get into some trouble. And before you know it,
everybody was being wild and nasty and one
man wanted to learn how to play the
piano. But his buddies were like, you ain't playing around here. Boy,
is this a meeting.
Theo? I'll do.
This. John Travolta. Impersonation.
Okay.
[inaudible] how long have you been at up?
Um, about 14 years. Did you hear about Henry Winkler? 14 years.
Yup. He got.
Tough crowd by the way. The sandwich is very good. Thank you for like great.
I'm glad.
I think Rick has taken on some new knowledge today.
I think he learned what it feels like to be appreciated,
what it feels like when he dresses up and takes care of his appearance,
you could tell, he felt good. And this is, I think the real Rick,
this is the Rick that he wants to be. What'd you think?
I don't know. I feel different. Yeah. Yeah.
Like not just from the, the shave and haircut.
When the times got.
Tough when John was losing it, when it was a lot of stress up there.
He didn't lose it.
I just hope that I can take some of this and
make my mom's life a little bit better.
It's like she doesn't ask for a lot, you know?
And I feel like such a piece of that I'm.
Yeah. We'll just love her, you know?
Yeah. It doesn't mean it's like all it's all you can really do is like,
just try to try better. And now that I feel like I've gotten, like you said,
momentum, it's like something I can.
And just keep it going. Keep it going. The rest will come. Manny will come.
Oh, mom's here. Oh.
Hey, you guys look great.
He certainly looks at, I think Rick learned a lot in the past few days. I mean,
he's going to be able to take this experience and hopefully go forth and,
and let it resonate and ripple through his life in positive ways.
At a certain point, we have to grow up.
I'm learning a lot of the same things that he is, and it's hard,
but it's possible. Okay. Wow.
You look so handsome. Cut all this stuff off of me.
I'm going to take everything that I learned and I'm going to apply it
to us and I'm going to be better about the housework and stuff that
needs to be done. And I'll be better about taking care of you.
I really appreciate that. Proud of you and I love you.
[inaudible] good evening. Good afternoon. And other times.
Thanks for watching that video. You just saw. I mean, it was okay,
but the next video you could watch, it could be way better.
What if you watch a video right now that changes your life where you could watch
this one. Ah,